few people are more pro-russian than
this man Igor gherkin at the beginning
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine in
February the self-described ultra
nationalists was a staunch supporter of
the Russian military predicting its
Advanced weaponry and skilled soldiers
would make easy work of the outnumbered
ukrainians
but now gherkin's tone has changed
I have an impression that in October our
Russian army will break into pieces it's
not because they are incompetent or
covertly it's because the Ukraine army
supply lines are much much better than
ours
in the past week during the Ukrainian
counter-offensive countless videos
appeared to show a Russian military and
collapse but throughout this war Moscow
has been particularly Adept at staying
silent and refusing to admit or even
acknowledging setbacks
the tone on Russian State TV talk shows
which for months refrained from any
criticism of the invasion has changed
dramatically with people pointing
fingers at who's to blame for the losses
on the battlefield
people who convinced President Putin the
Special Operation would be fast that we
won't strike civilians that our military
would keep things in order these people
really set us up for this they lied to
us
and on another talk show this we can't
win a full-scale military operation
using only the Russian army and this
talk show and other propaganda the
Ukrainian military offensive in the
Northeast has clearly broken the Russian
front lines but also exposed to deep
cracks within the pro-russia Blogger
community that is now questioning
everything about this war
will it be enough for the Kremlin to
change their tactics or is the Kremlin
even listening
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Keith